well let's find out how businesses in
northern ireland are faring
we can talk to patricia gilbert from the
bali lagan organic farm in bali claire
in county antrim uh thank you for being
with us we're looking at the politics of
all this but
what about the practicalities how are
you being
impacted by the checks and the
restrictions
well we run an organic farm we also have
a
farm shop and up until this year we
relied
very heavily on gb wholesalers for about
70 of our turnover we're now
in february and some of these
wholesalers say that they're still
unable to send produce across the rsc
right so you say unable to is that
because
they don't want to because of all the
extra
paperwork is is and possible delays i
guess to their produce
yes indeed i mean it's the amount of
paperwork that's required
the cost in terms of staff time
to fill everything in and then of course
the concern that produce particularly
fresh produce might get held up with the
ports
and so what are the particular
difficulties they're they're worried
about as a result of the new
restrictions is it is it simply the
paperwork you describe
or are there additional costs what are
the
the specific problems well certainly
there are additional costs and i'm
having to pay more
to get produce in from gb
but if i can give you one example we are
getting some organic fruit and veg from
a wholesaler in england
and they have to supply the courier
with all the information that's required
for the customs
documents they also have to upload
a full list of all the produce onto
the defrost website for a fatal sanitary
certificate which actually involves a
desperate
person having to come out and look at
the pallet of fruit and veg
and then come april
they will also have to get a certificate
of inspection because the goods they are
moving
are organic so that would be the third
level of inspection
and certificates right i mean boris
johnson
suggested that these could be teething
problems um
and also suggested that northern ireland
businesses could
have the best of both worlds um how is
it it's not turning out that way i guess
no and i i've spoken to a lot of other
businesses and it's not
actually just northern ireland because
the south of ireland is
as retailers are very effective as well
because
we all relied um on gb
wholesalers to a large extent
particularly for organic produce
so are you um having to source goods and
produce now from the eu are you looking
at other countries that would be
you know be simpler to deal with
well i have just placed my first order
with a large
dutch organic wholesaler um so we shall
see how that works
um but yes i mean if you know i didn't
really want to have to do that but i'm
i'm forced
down that road right so what would you
like to see happen
as talks going on i mean do you think
this this can be
resolved would you like to see a an
extension to the grace period would that
be enough
no i i don't think it's just about
extending the grace period i think
it has to be fixed um if
these regulations are in place to stop
the movement
of goods from northern ireland across
the border
downside in other words as a back door
to eu and i think they have to look at
where
the actual risk is and
where these goods are actually arriving
in northern ireland and
i'm a retailer i'm bringing in pallets
of maybe one to two hundred lines i'm
going to sell it out of
a farm shop there isn't no risk that i
am going to move those goods
across the border into the south of
ireland and i think there has to be a
much more pragmatic approach to this
okay well we'll see what happens
patricia gilbert uh thank you for
uh being with us this evening